we're Jewish it's Christmas there's no
Yuletide cheer so bugger the eggnog and
the reindeer that is not a Jewish thing
I've never touched a Christmas tree I
assume if I did like my hands would burn
or some things it's just about glitter
and Christmas sucks I feel like I'll be
pretty good at this Christmas sweater
let's see what we have here why do they
make Jesus a baby
anything with a hook on it let's put on
the tree sounds pretty good
yeah I just know oh wait we've got eyes
under it too
okay oh that's not so hard she has a
nice little angel yarmulke like he's on
there
she needs about the tree looks delicious
smells great this tree looks super fake
this is tacky this cuz we're Jewish we
know what real trees look like
I guess candy canes are good at hanging
on trees because they're definitely
terrible candy you like if my family did
this we would just leave the tree up
forever because we would no one would
want to clean it up
like look at this skirt it's not even
covering her knees our pinecones is that
Christian is this the Virgin Mary hello
Mary had wings my understanding is the
guys sing while they do this oh yes no
oh could you name those seven reindeer
gallant no like a grassy knoll who-who
is Noel is Noel gone is it Jesus or
dancer answer lemony nope kind of a rap
parts of it in aluminum foil like
conspiracy theory tree crime a lot of
them right that's the dancer Prancer
Gandalf yeah you put the huh you wanna
go to hell one two three
yeah Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
those are definitely a fire hazard I
feel like if a rabbi sees this they're
gonna kick me out of Judaism I'm not a
Jew anymore right I think I killed it I
don't know why everyone's always making
a big deal about decorating the
Christmas tree I feel like we did it
pretty quickly and totally kicked ass
how do you feel now that you
Christmas tree like a whole new person I
give it like a B we forgot one thing
missile tough yeah I'm reasonably sure
we got everything